major Garrett is CBS News chief White
House correspondent and with us here in
studio 57 good morning let's talk about
this the president clearly making this a
political issue talking about it at a
rally in Texas how does it play out
though two weeks from now to look at a
Senate race this issue matters but in a
house race it doesn't and let's think
about House races what's the real
midterm election question do Democrats
win back control the house think of
California where I grew up
this issue in this story plays very
differently in California where seven
house Republican seats are very much up
for grabs
so this story does play well for the
Trump base in Montana
Missouri perhaps other states but in
House races and maybe the most important
place for a lot of House races
California it works against the
president and Republican interest so you
can't think of this issue as
all-or-nothing it is a base mobilizer in
certain places it can hurt in other
places do you leak that from Election
Day right this feels like a different
kind of midterm it does that to you too
it feels like a national election does
it not and there is a sense in the
polling data that energy in both parties
is at historic highs we've never seen
that before usually if it's a midterm
one party's up the other party's
depressed
that's the Trump effect I write in my
book mr. Trump's wild rise at under
Trump politics feels primal everything
feels nationalized why because he always
wants to be the center of every
conversation and these rallies he's
going to do two a day for the six days
up to the election two rallies a day in
the White House's told me that's intense
personalization of national politics so
he humps way whether or not it is a
referendum in some ways on president and
he wants to make it that and his
supporters look at that and say he's out
there strong and bold we need to be out
there for him he knows that if he
retreats this becomes a democratic
conversation he doesn't want that to
happen there's also a difference between
attending a rally and then going to the
voting booth and voting for a guy or
some woman you don't know it's not
Donald Trump right what do we know about
we know in the past the transitive
property hasn't worked presidents of
campaign but people haven't turned out
is it gonna be different with Trump
everything is different with Trump and
you have to at least appreciate the fact
that people who show up in thousands as
they did in 2016 may in fact listen to
this and the president has said it's me
and it's Republicans I'm transferring it
I just doesn't usually happen but I
different and you're different and this
movement is different everyone is
traumatized properly so about what was
missed in 2016 so is this great sense of
anxiety and I think we all have to admit
we don't know what's gonna happen on
election night we just don't because
none of the predictive value of what
happened in 2006 2010 2014 other been
terms that were important is relevant in
the trump era because Trump changes the
dynamic the conversation the enthusiasm
models look at early voter turnout huge
off the charts we don't know what it
means yeah we just know it's big yeah
with big comes variables and
unpredictability yeah so we got to stay
tuned yes we do yeah that's right on
your local CBS station major thanks so
much major we'll be with you for the
next two weeks probably every day